Have you perhaps ever had the
feeling that computers are windows
out of the window so far I've
done it several
times really actually done it was
nice to have you maybe had the
feeling that computers are going to be out of the
window
so I'd have to go shopping  well
no actually not no i have to
be honest we have perhaps
had the feeling that you
just want to have your computer out of the window
yes it's often ok and
what happened there or why if
something doesn't work if you
don't send e-mails  can send it away if you have
any problems a program yes
that has happened to me more than once i am
technically not very versed in a
rheiner user and that happens all the time
and he is an internet is fast
it always works smoothly
it looks but the
speed it has so  to be
desired how important is the internet in
his daily life  in your life
the internet really does play a big
role in your life
it's important, but then there's
a platform like facebook, all the
social media networks, i don't pay attention to it
now, it's big, but it also
plays a role,
yes, i'm spending a lot of time in the
so the internet
was mainly series on the internet
or i'm on youtube and for me it was
simply a substitute for the tv
because i can choose on the internet
what i really want to watch
and if i have
to wait for advertising on tv, etc.
and have that  i don't do anything on the internet
yes yes yes i would also like to
just keep in touch on the internet, for
example at salz facebook
or other countries i think it's quite good to
just keep in touch with people
you don't know what you are risky for example
and that's exactly that  internet and
that already spends so much time
actually due to
work you can no longer look at the internet
w  For example, if you look at it that way,
my entire job actually runs on
flour and the Internet as a source of information
is used for several hours a day. In my private life,
I'm rather little if mostly
just music or
video
clips  sending emails i am
now above all the internet and
also facebook to get in touch with my friends in the
family of my family sometimes at the
other end of the world
so that's something like skype
or skype too yes and then of course
also
minister google because you  everything
always after but I have to say so
watch a lot more and something
less because I still like
to occupy myself with other things. Do you think
anything in your life would
change if your internet were so
fast
all of a sudden I would maybe upload more videos
upload youtube
that's nice if you have fast
internet  because he came to
use it more efficiently during this time do you think if
the internet is available then
i can do my work much faster
have to spend a lot of time on the internet
really not bother that much anymore
if it gets there quicker
find me under single fathers and yes
well i don't just do blogs but
also sometimes parodies or what
i feel like doing more often a
letter to new zealand takes a week
if it goes well and so who do you have
in new zealand my son and joy and
yes i have in other distant countries too
we are also happy that we were told something
also in the usa that's how it is with the
internet wraps great I used to have
huge phone bills and
now do it with skype or
how is the internet connection now tell us
your opinion on our
schreiber facebook page